Title: CNN This Morning - ukraine bts part
Channel: 1 - CNN
Recorded On: 5/15/2023 6:00:00 AM
Original Air Date: 5/15/2023
Transcript Generated by SnapStream
==================================
>> We should stop while we're ahead.
I'm right.
They tell me.
>>> President zelenskyy is meeting today with
British prime minister from the united Kingdom.
He announced a new package of support for
Ukraine's military.
That includes hundreds of air defense missiles
ahead of the highly anticipated spring offensive.
He also promised to start training Ukrainian
fighter pilots this summer.
That is key.
He has said fighter jets are on the table.
He has not yet taken that step.
President zelenskyy has been touring nato
countries looking to bolster support for Ukraine.
He traveled over the weekend to meet the chancellor
of Germany.
Also president macron in France and Italy's
president.
Also pope Francis while he was there at the
Vatican.
>>> On top of this, "The Washington post"
reported that classified documents leaks reveal
that president zelenskyy,
[6:03:35 AM]
reveal that president zelenskyy, the believes,
is plotting an attack inside of Russia.
The officials are not aware of him using U.S.
Provided weapons to attack Russia.
Sam, good morning.
What is key here?
Obviously, it is key to get that British training
of Ukrainian fighter pilots.
But what else comes out of this meeting today?
>> Well, it comes towards the end of, we didn't
know he was actually going to even attend
this meeting in London.
We thought there was -- it was European tour
that president zelenskyy.
We've been in Rome, Berlin, and then in Paris
and now in London.
All three places he's managed to secure full
support of very key important powerful European
nations.
In the case of Germany, $3 billion almost
of military aid.
In the case of the united Kingdom, yet another
pledge.
This time among other things for anti-aircraft
missiles and very
[6:04:35 AM]
anti-aircraft missiles and very important
fighter jet training program.
Now, the Brits have said that the Ukrainians
actually backed away from asking the British
for typhoon.
But they have added their voice to president
zelenskyy's in saying that they would like
to see the world that the allies supporting
Ukraine give Ukraine F-16s.
That has not yet happened.
But what this does do is cement support hindu
crane in a very material sense ahead of this
anticipated summer offensive.
>> It's very unlikely that Ukrainians would
exploit it.
They have driven the Russians to the north
and south promoting the organization to say
that they're fearful they may get
[6:05:36 AM]
they're fearful they may get encircled by
Ukrainian troops.
They've been able to exploit friction between
Wagner and the regular Russian arms forces,
a lack of coordination.
And part of -- I think this is significant
in the wider, psychological campaign -- president
zelenskyy's trip to Europe is part of which
is saying to the ordinary Russian soldier,
you may not live to see the end of this year.
We've got a lot of gear.
We've got a lot of initiative.
We've got a lot of intelligence.
We can reach out now behind your lines with
things like storm shadow from the United Kingdom
with our own Ukrainian built cruise missiles
that you're seeing in action.
We can get behind you and start knocking off
your logistic support.
Trying to break the will of the
Ukraine's president zelenskyy is meeting with
prime minister rishi sunak.
Mr. Zelenskyy is fresh off a weekend a stops
in European capitals, to meet with other key
allies.
>> France and Germany publicly pledged additional
military aid for Ukraine's war against Russia,
and prime minister sunak will do the same.
The uk's package will include air defense
missiles and new attack drones with a range
of more than two and kilometers.
For more on the story, we're joined by Clare
Sebastian.
Clare, I mean we gave an obvious hint of just
what the objectives of this trip have been.
What are zelenskyy's key priorities to take
away from this visit?
>> So, I think, obviously weapons are the
key thing.
He came off a really big pledge from Germany,
a three billion dollar package was promised
over the weekend, including another 30 leopard
tanks.
France is sending more armed vehicles, and
now we have the uk with these air defense
systems and air defense missiles and attack
drones.
So, clearly, look, we're
[4:02:34 AM]
So, clearly, look, we're heading into this
counter offensive that a statement from downing
street says this is coming as Ukraine's prepares
for an intensified period of military activity.
So, they're trying to step up support, so
that Ukraine has it needs.
Though there is an interesting part of the
statement that there has been a slight shift
in tone when it comes to fighter jets, fighter
jets like f-16s.
The last time that zelenskyy was in the uk
in February, uk was very clear that is meant
to train.
Came out in front, and said we are going to
train fighter pilots.
But this is about Ukraine's long term capital
is.
Now, we have a statement saying they're going
to start an elementary flying face for a cohort
of Ukrainian pilots a summit.
This training, the statement says, goes hand
in hand with efforts to work with other countries
to provide f-16 jets, Ukraine's fighter jets
of choice.
So, it looks like uk is stepping up pressure.
It is a country that likes to step up in front
with the six.
For zelenskyy, I think this is also very clearly
about optics.
He has done this all along.
He wants to be seen as taking his place among
these nato countries, among these eu countries.
Of course, this is coming ahead of the g7
summit this week, the really important nato
summit in
[4:03:36 AM]
really important nato summit in July.
So, I think that's part of it as well.
>> In terms of the counteroffensive, obviously,
you don't know exactly when it's going to
be.
But is there any sensible get to a position
soon where he is confident enough to go in?
>> Well, he did say over the weekend that
the first important steps will be happening
soon.
They're obviously going to be very cagey in
what they're offering, the announcement of
details about this,.
We are those seeing that Ukraine is having
some incremental success around bakhmut, who
are just a few weeks ago Russia had the upper
hand.
We're hearing this morning from the commander
of the land forces there they've seen the
first success in the defense of bakhmut.
But he called it a partial success.
The deputy defense minister saying that Ukraine
has been advancing for several.
Days although, against all the odds.
She says Russia is not changing at schools,
and they've been moving aerosol units to the
outside of bakhmut.
But it looks like things are edging on the
Ukraine side there, but still extremely difficult.
>> Is there a concern in Ukraine about war
fatigue setting in for European
[4:04:36 AM]
setting in for European partners, nato allies
such as the U.S., is that also what this trip
is about?
>> You know, I think that zelenskyy is probably
keenly aware of that.
And that is why these optics matter.
Obviously, since 2014, this has been about
Ukraine's desire to be part of Europe.
So, he is in a sense bringing that to some
degree to fruition for his people, with these
meetings.
And he's grown in confidence in order to do
this.
You know, for I think the first nine or ten
months of the war, he did not leave Ukraine
wants.
Then had that big trip to the U.S.
In December.
The European tour in February, and now a second
tour, I think you'd see him in Berlin on Sunday.
But that's why these optics matter, because
they matter for the Ukrainian people, who
want this to be their result.
And of course, it matters for